ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิงสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนที่หาได้ทุกคน
แมวสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีเนาะผู้หญิงก็สบายดี
ใช่ไหมคะใช่แล้วค่ะสบายดีวันนี้เราสองคน
จะมาคุยกันเรื่องอะไรนะคะครูฟ้า
เรื่องกีฬาฟุตบอลมีค่ะ
น่าน
เธอกีฬากีฬาตัวอย่างในรูปนี้ก็คือกีฬา
ฟุตบอลกีฬาฟุตบอลจัดเรียงจะมาคุยกัน
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับกีฬาแปลว่าเราสองคนที่ชอบ
เล่นกีฬานะไหมครูฟ้าชอบเล่นกีฬาไหมคะ
ไม่ห่าฮ่าๆๆอ่ะไม่ชอบหมาชอบเช้านี้หน่อย
ใช่ไหมหน่อยเออๆหน่อยค่ะผู้หญิงนะคะผู้
หญิงชอบเล่นกีฬาไหมคะไม่ชอบเธอ
โอเคนะไม่ชอบเล่นก็อาจจะชอบดูและเธอได้
TV อะไรเงี้ยหรือว่าอะไรนะโอลิมปิกรีนี้
ใช่ไหมปีนี้มีโอลิมปีกลิมปิกก็จะมีการ
แข่งขันกีฬาหลายๆชนิดมาซึ่งคนที่ไป
โอลิมปิคเขาก็เป็นนักกีฬานักกีฬาก็จะเก่ง
พี่เก่งประเทศไทยประเทศอเมริกาประเทศ
อังกฤษก็จะมีคนเก่งๆมาแข่งกีฬากันซึ่งเขา
จะเล่นกีฬาเป็นเล่นเป็นสายค่ะ
จ่ายค่าแรงเราสองคนเนี่ยอาจจะไม่ชอบแต่
มันก็จะมีกีฬาที่เราสองคนเนี่ยเล่นเป็น
แม่เข้ามาดูใช่
ก็มาดูว่าสื่อเราจะเล่นกีฬาอะไรเป็นหรือ
ไม่เป็นผู้ชายไม่ชอบยังไงล่ะคะหรือว่า
เก่งไม่เก่งยังไงตายกีฬาชนิดที่หนึ่งเลย
ค่ะครูฟ้าอะไรคะผู้หญิงว่ายน้ำ
กีฬาว่ายน้ำหรอไปแล้วครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำเป็น
ไหมคะครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำเป็นค่ะโห
เก่งไหมคะเก่งด้วย
ดีไซน์ก็ได้และค่ะ
ถ้าอะไรนะสีเรือไปเสื้อไหมหรือกบ
Jelly ไม่แม่นเลยเหรอก็ว่ายน้ำตีทรายกัน
เพียงแบบพี่น้องษาไทยปลาว่ายน้ำเก่งโหเคย
เป็นแชมป์ไหมคะไม่เคยค่ะไม่เคยไปแข่งไม่
เคยหรือ
ผู้หญิงราคาคู่หญิงว่ายน้ำเป็นไหมคะไม่
เป็นค่ะเฮ้ยไว้ไม่เป็นไม่เป็น freestyle
เนี่ยอ๋อไม่ได้ฉันเชียงไม่ได้ๆว่ายน้ำไม่
เป็นถ้ากูหญิงเนี่ยตกน้ำ
ช่วยด้วยช่วยด้วยช่วยด้วยๆ
เพราะว่าว่ายน้ำไม่เป็น
ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นเลยฉันก็ไม่เก่งไม่เก่งค่ะ
ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นก็ไม่เก่งแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ว่ายน้ำเป็นแล้วถ้าเก่งจริงๆใจแล้วมาดู
กีฬาต่อไปค่ะนายหากินอ่ะต่อไปคือฟุตบอล
โอ้โหพรครูฟ้าเล่นฟุตบอลเป็นไหมคะครูฟ้า
เล่นฟุตบอลไม่เป็นฮะค่ะหาไม่เป็นน่ะคือ
เล่นไม่เป็นและก็เล่นไม่เก่งเนาะเพราะว่า
มันเป็นทรายเล่นไม่เป็นค่ะคุณหญิงมาหาผู้
หญิงเล่นฟุตบอลเป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นค่ะไม่
เป็นเหมือนกันเพราะว่าตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆ
สมัยกีฬาฟุตบอลกับผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่เล่นผู้
หญิงไม่เล่นฟุตบอลแต่ถ้าเป็นผู้ชายในใน
รูปเนี่ยเป็นผู้ชายผู้ชายเนี่ยคิดว่าผู้
ชายไทยน่าจะประมาณ 80  90 เปอร์เซ็นต์
เล่นฟุตบอลผลิต
ถ่ายน่าจะชอบเล่นฟุตบอล
ก็ขยันผู้หญิงมีน้องชายไปกู้หญิงมาก็น้อง
น้องชายเนี่ยเล่นฟุตบอลเป็นแล้วก็เก่ง
น้ำเก่งๆเคยแล้วก็ชอบฟุตบอลมากๆ
[เพลง]
ได้อะไรแต่เราสองคนไม่เป็นลืมไม่เป็นไม่
เป็นเลยดูเนี่ยเวลาดูนะเข้าใจนิดหน่อยนะ
อ๋อ
ผู้หญิงก็ดูดูฟุตบอลแหละเข้าใจชนะ
ทีมไหนจ๊ะ
แต่ไม่เข้าใจร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์นะอ่ะเข้าใจ
บ้าง 70-80 เปอร์เซ็นต์สำหรับกีฬาฟุตบอล
ใช้
จะต่อไปค่ะหน้าต่อไปคืออะไรคะกอล์ฟโต้ตอบ
กับสีฟ้าตีกอล์ฟเป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นค่ะ
ถ้าเป็นกอล์ฟที่เป็นออกกอล์ฟเดี๋ยวไม่
เป็นถ้าเป็นกอล์ฟที่เป็นแอพพลิเคชั่นเกม
ในโทรศัพท์นี่เล่นเป็นนะคะ
แล้วถ้าเป็นกีฬากองเนี่ยไม่เป็นอ่ะอยาก
เล่นเกมเก่งเป็นละเอง
กีฬากอล์ฟไม่เป็นค่ะชายพาเล่นเป็นสิ่งก็
ไม่เป็นเหมือนกันมีอะไร
แพง
หน้าที่แปลไทยอ่ะแพงหรอนหมายต้องใช้สาย
ไม้กอล์ฟเนี่ยเนาะไม้กอล์ฟชุดใช่ไหมค่ะ
เสื้อกางเกงหมวกรองเท้า
แทงหัวงูถ้าคนเล่นกอล์ฟเป็นเหนียว
มีเงินนะรวยๆก็ไปเล่นแบบโอลิมปิคเลยฮะอ่ะ
ผมไม่ใช่สายอย่างถ้าคนที่เล่นกอล์ฟเก่งๆ
ก็ Tiger  Woods ใช่ไหมคะไข่ the  woods
ในเก่งหรือว่าผู้หญิงไทย 1 คนสมัยโปรมีก็
รัฐของมีจ่ายเก่ง
กีฬาต่อไปค่ะยาต่อไปเลยค่ะว่ากอล์ฟไม่ใช่
เราจะดูซิว่าเรามันจะมีกีฬาที่เราสองคน
เนี่ยเล่นเป็นไหม
น้อยว่ายน้ำต่อไปค่ะยังไม่มีเลยน้องพี่
หล้าไว้ค่ะ
บาสเกตบอล Over สเก็ตบอลครูฟ้าเล่น
บาสเก็ตบอลเป็นไหมคะลูกค้าเล่นบาสเก็ตบอล
เต้นนะคะ
ตอนเด็กๆตอนเด็กๆใช่ไหมตอนอายุประมาณ 10
16 อะไรอายุเท่าไหร่นะ 12  2 ตัวอายุมา
12 เนี่ย
กูมาเล่นบาสเก็ตบอลเก่งนะเพราะเล่นเป็น
แล้วก็เล่นมีด้วยหรอคะถูกต้องอ่ะ
หนูเคยเป็นแชมป์ไหมลูกค้าเคยเป็นแชมป์ไหม
คะออไม่เคยเป็นแชมป์อ่ะแต่ว่าเล่นกับ
เพื่อนใช่มั้ยเล่นบาสเก็ตบอลแล้วก็มีครีม
ทีมโอ้มาเล่นเก่งนะชนะสวยกูปลาชนะเย้ชนะ
ให้ท้องฟ้าแล้วก็กูฟ้าตัวสูง
สูงสูงหน้าสำหรับผู้หญิงฟ้าสูงเป็นคนโทร
หา
แล้วครูเขียนเล่นคะถ้ากูไปเล่นบาสเก็ตบอล
เต้นก็เล่นบาสเก็ตบอลเจ่งคิดขาเก่ง
ผู้หญิงมาเล่นบาสเก็ตบอลเป็นไหมคะเป็นค่ะ
แต่ไม่เก่ง
มีลูกพรรคมีลูกบาสมาแล้วก็จะ 4 ชุดได้
แต่ที่
เพราะว่าตอนเด็กๆเคยเรียนสมัยเคยเรียนก็
เล่นเป็นจับรู้รู้ว่าทำยังไงแต่ไม่เก่ง
ใช่ไหมคะไม่เก่งคิดว่าตอนนี้เราสองคนก็
ไม่ค่อยโอเคแล้วครับเพราะว่าเราใส่แว่น
เออถ้าใส่แว่นเล็กตาสเก็ตบอลไม่ได้เนาะ
น้องไม่เห็นไงบอกเวลา
ถ่ายค่ะน้องเอาก็นี้เราสองคนเล่นเป็นแต่
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นเก่งครูหญิงเนี่ยเล่นไม่
เก่งชายเล่นเป็นกีฬาต่อไปค่ะ
[เพลง]
ต่อไป
ปิงปอง
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าเล่นปิงปองเป็นไหมคะครูหาเล่น
ปิงปองไม่เป็นค่ะจนออที่จริงคือฟ้าเคยดู
ล่ะดูกับเวลาเขาเล่นกันนาซ่ากุมภาไม่เคย
เล่นปิงปองไม่เคยเล่นปิงปองเลยก็เลยค่ะ
เด็กๆเด็กๆจนโตเนี่ย
000 เปอร์เซ็นต์ปิงปองก็เต็มถูกต้องสูญ
ไม่เล่นไม่เป็นเลยไม่เป็นเลยอ่ะไม่เคย
เล่นเลยก็ครูหญิงละฮาเล่นปิงปองเป็นไหมคะ
เป้นค่ะ
เด็กๆไม่เคยเล่นเป็นโป่งเออ
เก่งด้วยนะหญิงด้วยหรอ
[เพลง]
ชายที่บ้านที่บ้านเนี่ยมีอ่าไม้ปิงปอง
แล้วก็ลูกปิงปองแล้วก็เล่นนะ
เวลาคนนักเรียนดูมึงจะได้ยินเสียงในเป็น
ลูกปิงปองในโอ๊ย
ตายใช่แต่จ่ายเล่นเป็นค่ะแล้วก็เก่งๆเก่ง
แล้วไม่เคยเป็นแชมป์นะ
แต่รู้ไงเราจะรู้ว่าจะเล่นโอเคเล่นก็คือ
ตัวเราใช้ครูหญิงคนเดียวเนี่ยผู้หญิงคิด
เนาะเล่นปิงปองเป็นแล้วก็เล่นเก่งแต่ถ้า
เป็นผู้หญิงครูฟ้าคุณเอคุณบีอีกหรืออันจะ
ไม่เก่งไปแต่ถ้าผู้หญิงคนเดียวสำหรับกีฬา
ใส่เพราะว่าอ้ะ
บาสเกตบอลเนี่ยไม่เก่งแต่จริงป่องเนี่ย
เก่งค่ะ
เฮ้อกีฬาต่อไปกีฬาต่อไปคืออะไรคะคิดว่า
คิดว่ากีฬาอันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าน่าจะเล่น
เก่งคิดเก่งคิดเอ้ยเออแต่ไม่รู้ว่าครูฟ้า
จะเล่นเก่งหรือเปล่าว่านะ
นั่นก็คือแบดมินตัน
ร้านลุงใหญ่
เล็กม้าเล่นแบดมินตันเป็นใช่ไหมคะเล่น
เป็นไหมค่ะขวาเล่นแบบนี้ตั้งเต็นท์รักฟ้า
ก็เล่นเก่ง
และก็ชอบเล่นแบบนิลตันด้วยหาทำไมถึงชอบ
อ่ะก็รู้สึกสนุกอ่ะเวลาเล่นอยู่เหมือนเรา
ได้เล่นแบบกับเพื่อนใช่มั้ยทุกคนคิดว่า
มันแบบมันง่ายอ่ะก็แค่มีมีลูกใช่มั้ยคน
กันนี่เนาะไม่รู้กันฝนได้แล้วก็มีไม้แบต
นี้แล้วก็เห็นนะคะ ttp เยอะๆสนุกชอบตอน
นี้ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเล่นแบดมินตันไหมคะ
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ไม่ได้เล่นถ้าไม่ได้เล่นแล้ว
ค่ะก็ใส่แว่นด้วย
ใส่แว่นน่ะเล่นแบดมินตันมาทุกคนมันก็เถอะ
มองก็ไม่เห็นจริงๆจะเล่นแบดมินตันนี้ต้อง
ตาดีนะตาโร่กุนเพราะคุณต้องดูใช่ไหมต้อง
ดูมีขนไก่อ่ะหน้าเวลาผู้หญิงตีให้กูกะกู
ฟ้าก็ต้องห้องอยู่ที่ไหนอ่ะ
ถ้าเล่นแบดมินตันก็ต้องถอดแว่นไม่ต้องถอด
แหวน
อันนี้ก็ไม่ได้เล่นแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงคะกูมา
เล่นเป็นใช่
ผู้หญิงชอบผู้หญิงเล่นแบดมินตันเป็นไหมคะ
เป็นค่ะเล่นเป็นเล่นเป็นมันเกี่ยวเล่น
ด้วยกันได้นะ
จะไม่เก่งนะไม่เก่งไม่เก่งธรรมดาสมัย
ธรรมดาอย่างผู้หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ย
เล่นปิงปองเก่งถึงจะไหมคะเล่นบาสเก็ตบอล
เนี่ยอ่ะไม่เก่งแต่ว่าแบดมินตันเนี่ย
ธรรมดา
ใจคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าว่าแบดมินตันเนี่ยเล่น
ง่ายๆสมัยคุณน่ะไม่ต้องเก่งมากๆก็เล่น
แบดมินตันว่างๆก็เลยคิดคิดเหมือนครูฟ้า
ว่าเอ่อค่อนข้างช่อแบดมินตันถึงเวลาวิ่ง
ใช้ค่ะแล้วก็ก็คิดว่าแบบนี้ตันอย่าเล่น
ได้ทุกที่ไงเออ
มันง่ายๆอ่ะอยู่ที่บ้านลูกค้าอยู่บ้าน
พัทยาก็เล่นได้มาอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์เล่นได้
เส้นด้ายคอนโดมาเล่นได้
ชายเล่นแบดมินตันได้
ง่ายใจค่ะน้องอ่ะกีฬาต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้ากีฬา
ต่อไปคืออะไรก็คิดว่าเป็นกีฬาที่ครูฟ้า
น่าจะชอบมากๆวิเคราะห์
What กร
ครูฟ้าเล่นวอลเลย์บอลเป็นไหมคะ
เล่นเล่นเป็นค่ะเล่นเล่นเล่นเก่งไหมเล่น
พี่เก่ง
ไม่เก่งแบบมากๆเลยอ่ะไม่เก็บเหรอไม่กี้
เก่งอ่ะต้องบอกเลยเนี่ย
ถ้าถ้าถ้าอะไรนะแบดมินตันเนี่ยเก่งมากๆๆ
เก่ง
วอลเลย์บอลก็คือไม่เก่งมากๆไม่เห็นไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบเลยแค่ไม่กี่ทำไมทำไมไม่ชอบมันแบบ
บอกว่าลูกมันเออวอลเลย์บอลใช่มั้ยเวลา
เล่นแล้วต้องใช้ข้อมือใช่ไหมคะค่ะอย่าง
เนี้ยเนาะมันเวลาเค้าตบตรงเนี้ยเนาะเขา
ต้องใช้ข้อมูลเธอให้ข้อมือแล้วมันเจ็บอ่ะ
อืมมันคู่มือครูปุ้ยเจ็บเจ็บป่ะก็ไม่ชอบ
ก็ไม่ชอบมากๆเลยอ่ะไม่ชอบคุณครูด้วยแหละ
หรือขอไม่ชอบก็เลยเล่นไม่เก่งใช่เพราะว่า
อยู่ไทยครูนะถ้ามีเป็น Coast เป็นแบบว่า
คุณครูเนี้ยแต่ป้าไม่ชอบครูวอลเลย์บอล
เหรอครูวอลเลย์บอลทำไมอ่ะกูทำอะไรคนมา
เหรอโค้งชอบพูดไม่ดีอย่างเงี้ยอะทำไมเล่น
ไม่ได้เฮ้อเมื่อยฮือครูฟ้าก็เลยไม่ชอบก็
เลยไม่เก่งถูกต้อง
ผู้หญิงน่ารักขี้เล่นเป็นค่ะเล่นเป็นเล่น
เป็นเล่นเป็นค่ะไม่เก่งค่ะเท่านั้น
โอเคนะเฉยๆ
สายแต่ไม่เก่งเลยอ่ะฟ้าเหมือนไม่เข้าใจ
อ่ะเวลาเล่นเหมือนไอ้คิวแบต IQ
วอลเลย์บอลเนี่ย 0 เมื่อไหร่ไม่เก่ง
เหมือนกันไม่เก่งนะเนี่ยเล่นเป็นแต่ไม่
เก่งนะคะไม่เก่งแต่ถ้าเราไม่โอเค
วอลเลย์บอลนะฮะใช้ใช่เออเหมือนเราสองคน
มั้ยไม่ค่อยชอบวอลเลย์บอลเนาะพี่ก็ไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบเธอจะดูได้นะดูการขนมเวลาดูสนุกตาย
แต่ถ้าให้เราเล่นเองเขาไม่ชอบแล้วก็ไม่
เก่งชายใครค่ะ
อันนี้ที่ผ่าว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นวัยรุ่น
น้องยังอายุนิดหน่อยครูฟ้าอ่ะเล่น
สเก็ตบอร์ด
สเก็ตบอร์ดหรอก็เป็นกีฬาใช่ไหมคะซื้อคัน
นี้เป็นสเก็ตบอร์ดเป็นสเก็ตบอร์ด
จ่ายก็คิดว่าใครๆกันนอกกับเซิฟ 7 แต่ว่า
เป็นสเก็ตบอร์ดครูฟ้าเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดเป็น
ไหมคะเรียนดูหน้าหูฟ้าหาถึงหน้าใช้
เล่นไม่เป็นค่ะ
แต่อยากเล่นหน่ะ 1
เต้นนะกีฬาสเก็ตมันเถอะจุดๆก็ได้อะไร
Extreme ไหมตอนครูหญิงถ้าเป็นเป็นวัย
รุ่นน่ะที่ลาสเก็ตบอร์ดเนี่ยอ่าเด็กๆสมัย
อายุ
18-19 จะเล่นแล้วก็เขาเรียกว่ากีฬา
Extreme เพราะมันจะแบบตื่นเต้นแบบ
ไม่ใช่ไหมคะเหมือนอย่างเงี้ยไม่เขาขึ้น
แล้วก็ลงต้องเก่งมากๆเก่งมากแล้วคือบอก
ว่าอยากเล่นมากอ่ะแถวเล่นไม่เป็นนะเรามา
เล่นไปค่ะใส่ได้ไม่เป็นแต่ว่าอยากเล่น
เล่นเล่นผู้หญิงเล่าอีกนั้นเป็นไหมไม่
เป็นไรค่ะไม่เป็นไม่เป็นใจไม่เคยไม่เคย
เล่นจ่ายคิดว่าในอ่าถ้าเป็นต่างประเทศ
น้อยอย่างยุโรปหรือว่าเมริกาหลายๆคนน่าจะ
เล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดเป็นแล้วก็บางคนก็เก่ง
ใช่คิดว่าอะไรการไฟฟ้ายากเล่นใช่มั้ยอยาก
เล่น
อยากเล่นมากไม่เคยเล่นน่ะใจแต่ตอนนี้ต้อง
รอนี่ดีนะให้ให้ให้สถานให้โคบิตขึ้นบิด
ได้นะคู่ผิดยังไม่บายว่าจะไปเล่น
สเก็ตบอร์ดใช้เป็นกีฬาสำหรับ
เล่นด้วยอ่ะออกกำลังกายด้วยมีเพื่อนด้วย
นะสำหรับกีฬาสเก็ตบอร์ดงานใส่จ่ายค่ะเรา
กินกันอาจใดๆๆ
อันนี้ก็คือฟ้าอาจจะอยากเล่นก็ได้เพราะ
ว่าครูฟ้าบอกว่าบ้านครูฟ้าแน่อยู่พัทยา
ใต้หากท่านนักเรียนเชยมาประเทศไทยก็จะรู้
ว่าพัทยานามิทะเล
ใจเป็นทะเลก็กีฬานี้ก็คือคนไทยได้เท่า
ไหร่อ่ะกระดานโต้คลื่น
นะคะมีจะมีแผ่นกระดานใช่แล้วก็มีคลื่นหนู
โอ๋ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นเป็นไหมเล่นไม่เป็นค่ะ
อยากเล่นไหมอันนี้อยากเล่นอยู่นะบ่เคย
เห็นคนแน่นแล้วเค้าดูแบบปูสนุกแข็งแรง
ต้องแข็งแรงว่างๆ
ไม่เป็นอยากเล่นอยู่กันเหมือนเป็นไหมคะ
เดี๋ยว
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยว่ายน้ำขออยู่
ใส่เสื้อยังไงคือที่
ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นให้เล่นกันโตขึ้นกันไม่ได้
ทั่วฟ้า
ช่วยด้วยช่วยด้วยก็ไม่ได้เขาไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้นะแต่ว่าลูกค้าเนี่ยกระดานโต้คลื่น
ก็เล่นไม่เป็น
ก็อยากเล่นอยากเล่นห่าขายเขาก็บอกว่ามี
กีฬานะสาบางอย่างเนี่ยเราเล่นไม่เป็นนะ
บางอย่างเราเล่นเป็น
แล้วก็ถ้าเล่นเป็นก็จะมีเล่อย่าเก่งกับ
เล่นไม่เก่งชายเก่งมากๆก็อาจจะไปโอลิมปิค
ใช่มั้ยคุณเล่นเก่งมากกูก็ไปแข่งโอลิมปิก
ได้ใช่ไหมแต่เล่นไม่เก่งก็ไม่เป็นไรก็
เล่นเป็นไรถ้าชอบก็เล่นไปหรือว่าเล่นไม่
เป็นไม่อย่างสเก็ตบอร์ดเลยเนี่ยเราสองคน
เล่นไม่เป็นแต่เราอยากเล่นอยาก
1 วันเนี่ยถอดชุด board  Game  Board
หรือว่าอะไรนะกระดานโต้คลื่น
กระดานโต้คลื่นเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็เล่นไม่เป็น
แต่กำลังอยากเล่นซะเลยคะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็พูดถึงกีฬาน้องว่าเราสอง
คนเนี่ยเล่นอะไรเป็นแล้วก็เล่นอะไรไม่
เป็นเก่งหรือเปล่าชายขาหรอแล้วค่ะวันนี้
เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเดินทาง
วีดีโอหน้าในหาดถ้าชอบก็อย่าลืมกดแชร์กด
ไลค์กับ Subscribe ด้วยนะคะไปแล้วก็บ๊าย
บายค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่า
[เพลง]